ينضم الينا من موسكو مراسل صباح العربيه
عبد الجواد الرشدي يسعد صباحك عبد الجواد
اهلا بك لطالما كانت روسيا بلد مهم
للسياحه لكن بعد الحرب الاوكرانيه الروسيه
كان هناك بعض التردد السياحي لكل من ينوي
او يريد زياره موسكو وروسيا كيف يبدو
الوضع اليوم
[موسيقى]
صباح الخير سهام وصباح الخير لنادين ايضا
طبعا متابعه طيبه من الصباح مع صباح
العربيه نعم بالفعل السهام يعني هي
اتفاقيات تسعى موسكو لتوقيعها مع العديد
من دول العالم لالغاء وتبسيط امور اجراءات
السفر للتمكن من الدخول للاراضي الروسيه
في ظل الوضع الراهن والضغط الكبير الذي
تعيشه موسكو من قبل الغرب طبعا يعني سهام
لا يمكن اخفاء طبيعه وروعه الاراضي
الروسيه بما يخص قضيه السياحه نحن نتحدث
عن موسكو الرائعه التي يعني تغنى وكتب
فيها الكثير من الشعراء والجميع يعرف
الكسندر بوشكر الشاعر الكبير وهو عميد
الشعراء الروس ايضا
اقصى الشرق الروسي القطب العديد من
المناطق الروسيه التي تلفت الانتباه لذلك
طبعا يعني
الموجودون في موسكو كنا نلاحظ خلال فصل
الصيف وجود طبعا عنصر السياحه من الدول
العربيه من الدول الخليجيه في شوارع لكن
طبعا مع توقيع هذه الاتفاقات قد نلحظ
تواجدا اكبر في شوارع المدينه تفضل
المدينه يعني اكيد ما في شك على جماليه
وعظمه روسيا وكمان انا اليوم بدي اسال
لانه انا من وحده من مخططات سفري هذه
السنه الى موسكو كيف بدي اتحمس اسافر
اليوم الى موسكو في ظل هذه ظروف الحاليه
هل الفنادق مهيه على ما يبدو انت بفندق
الان اذا يعني مش مخطئه والبنيه التحتيه
وكل شيء مهيئ لاستقبال السياح
[موسيقى]
نادين يعني انا تعمدت اليوم التواجد في
احد الفنادق يعني هذا المبنى هو احد
الابنيه السبعه وهي تسمى بابنيه ستالين
هذه الابنيه تعود لحقبه الاربعينيات
والخمسينيات من القرن الماضي كما نلاحظ
يعني هذا المبنى ومدخل هذا الفندق اشبه
بالمتحف نوعا ما طبعا هذا الشيء نلاحظه
ليس في الفنادق فحسب ايضا في محطات المترو
في شوارع المدينه المدينه حتى هذه اللحظه
لا يمكن التصديق نادين بان رغم الصعوبات
وجو الحرب الذي تعيشه البلاد الا ان روسيا
وموسكو تعيش حياتها الطبيعيه الكثير من
المحللين للوضع السياسي في البلاد تحدثوا
عن ضروره الانتقال من مرحله يعني الوضع
الطبيعي الى مرحله التوتر لحل الصراع مع
الغرب لكن على ما يبدو ان الشعب الروسي
الذواق في العيش في مدنه يعني يرغب
بالحياه الكريمه ما زالت حتى هذه اللحظه
كافه المرافق الحيويه المتاحف المطاعم
شوارع المدينه تعمل بشكلها الطبيعي بالرغم
من عدد الكبير من سياحه المدينه اما يخص
طبعا زيارتك يا نادين الى موسكو
تفضلي ابو عبد الجواد اضافه الى الصراع مع
الغرب هناك منافسه سياحيه مع اوروبا ومع
الغرب بالنسبه لروسيا ماذا عن الاسعار
وكيف سياحيا هيئه موسكو وروسيا الاجواء
لزياره اي سياح اليها
سهام يعني يعني المشكله الرئيسيه لدى
الروس تكمن في الطريقه غير الصحيحه
للترويج يعني هذه المعضله يراها الكثير من
سكان العالم يعني قبل بطوله كاس العالم في
عام 2018 التي استضافتها احدى عشره مدينه
روسيه كان الوضع مخفي نوعا ما يعني لا
يمكن للانسان العادي المقيم في دول اخرى
من معرفه الوضع في روسيا وما هي الاسعار
كيف تبدو المدن هل يعني على المراه ان
يجازف للوصول الى هذه المدن وتحمل هذا
العبء يعني لا يعرف ما هو ما ينتظره
والمجهول فيها لكن طبعا لكن بعض كاس
العالم بعد ان حضرت الناس الى يعني الى
المدن الروسيه وشاهدت الوضع طبعا بدا
الانفتاح الكبير على السياحه ولذلك طبعا
اصبح العالم
بالعديد من مناطقه يعرف بشكل كبير كيف
تبدو الاراضي الروسيه الاسعار طبعا هي
غاليه طبعا ما يعني موسكو تعتبر من ثاني
اغلى مدينه في العالم في الاجانب والمدينه
طبعا العمله الروسيه المعتمده في البلد
كمان هاي لاحظت كتير ناس عم بحكوا اخر
فتره انه تروح لهناك
وفش صرافين كثير عبد الجواد موجود
صحيح طبعا انتم بس شرفونا ونورونا